et maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette dernière fois en partant j'ai eu
le malheur de dire bonne nouvelle ça
s'est arrangé avec ma copine elle avorte
je m'en veux un peu parce que ce soir là
ma copine regardé et je me suis rendu
compte que ça pouvait créer quelques
tensions dans le couple non mais je veux
dire surtout quand on commence à appeler
ses plans cul ma copine et
c'est important quand même de bilbao que
sur cette loi de simone veil très grande
dame dont on célèbre les 40 ans pat
simmons la loi
et moi je voulais vraiment rendre
hommage à simone parce que liv et
j'essaie quand même la liberté de la
femme de disposer de son corps et de
l'homme de disposer de son rib
enfin si la femme est d'accord facile
comme quoi la lutte n'est pas finie et
peut-être qu'un jour dans ce pays les
les hommes auront les mêmes droits que
les femmes
[Applaudissements]
il paraît que je suis clivant très très
clivant par et il s'est vraiment les
gens qui n'aiment pas les gens qui
aiment un peu moins donc
alors géopolitique et internationale
livraison du mistral alors on a décidé
de reporter la livraison du mistral à la
russie je sens que c'est encore un truc
qui va finir sur le bon coin
à vendre porte hélicoptères ayant très
peu servi kilométrage nul très bon état
général fournies avec trois ouvriers
roumains soudé à la proue
ouvert aux échanges contre iphone 6 août
ont deux et de jardin
non mais on est bon on est bon on refuse
le mistral à la russie on veut vendre
des rafale au qatar il ne reste plus qu
à fourguer des missiles nucléaires à
l'iran et le virus de l'ebola à la corée
du nord et
ont cours au sans faute diplomatique
syndicalisme et volupté alors ça
concerne évidemment le chef de la cgt
après le logement refait pour cent
cinquante mille euros maintenant il
s'est fait faire un bureau pour soixante
deux mille euros mais bon le mec à façon
je veux pas stigmatiser parce que c'est
un peu facile gérer c'est qu'il est
comme ça quand il aime il compte pas
quoi tu as récemment il paraît qu'il a
investi 200 mille euros pour retaper sa
vieille clio
lui a mis des pneus de f1 en moteur de
f16 des siège d'airbus a380 c'est un
bijou le truc vraiment ce mec c'est un
passionné c'est un passionné encore
servir le tipi parent qui possèdent des
patins à roulettes qui l'a fait que
stomisés pour 32000 euros alors
attention la gomme des rousses effet en
cire humaines de rhinocéros blancs
et le cuir c de la peau de testicules
d'ours polaires super rare alors des
choses un peu plus légère en habile a
alors enfin c'est pas vraiment une
affaire légère c'est comme notre notre
affaire dreyfus contemporaine
veux dire c'est très passé mais je suis
là faire ce tour c'est tellement
passionnant ce passionnant c'est
l'époque faut comprendre son mec il a
parlé la conseille s'appelle thomas il a
dit dans latéralité vous êtes scrutés en
permanence
était temps qu'il se réveille bichon
bah oui thomas en fait le principe de la
télé-réalité c'est d'être filmé et
surtout quand t'es pas ton avantage donc
quand tu es au naturel
un moment tomate a même dit vous ne
pouvez pas comprendre au centro
la tonne tu marques un point on peut pas
comprendre
bah du coup elles restent en prison à
versailles fait les temps ont bien
changé tu vois avant tu commencé en
climent les ombres dans un boudoir tu
finissais en faisant rimer la tête à
paris là tu files des coups de canif
dans un appart hôtel à boulogne et tu
finis en pension complète à mersenne
[Applaudissements]
alors dernières nouvelles on a réussi à
lui arracher des aveux ça a été dur ils
n'ont pas mis dans une cellule en
isolement mais ils ont ramené dans la
bibliothèque
elle n'a pas supporté alors la meuf elle
était tellement mal qu'en plus de dire
ce qui s'est vraiment passé là aussi
donné le nom de l'assassin de kennedy et
du petit grégory
mais au-delà de tout ça il ya
nabila en prison pour tous les exclus du
sexe et c'est super nouvelle
bah oui parce qu'en prison
comment dirais-je
quand elle va devoir ramasser un savon
sous la douche
cognac des meufs
ne rien se passer
alors et la frustration
frustration alors va prendre sur elle et
sa montée
ouais ça monte ça monte et thierry
[ __ ] sa monture chaque jour chaque
jour un peu plus la sa remontée dans sa
tête elle habille la la ça ça cogite
ouais ça va cogiter
thierry ça cogite et beaucoup
beaucoup trop
matin midi et soir [ __ ] c'est la
qualité et pas que dans la tête à la
barre en prison et y aura pas beaucoup
de tendresse mais moi dehors devant la
grille de sortie moi je moi j'ai de la
tendresse à donner [ __ ] quand elle
sortira
patrick ça va être un carnage
s'arrêtera moi j'ai déjà pris les
devants j'ai déjà installé maths en
dessous les miradors là quand elle va
sortir moi je réponds plus de rien d'un
côté les chutes du niagara de l'autre
côté le karcher suisse
attends je suis chaud la grogne
alors est pas belle la vie et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de inler dit tu es
abonné vous y mettez un peu de bleu